the media clan is basically a family
tradition if you think about it i mean
at one time in america with so many
members during the 1920s one out of
three americans
members of the kkk yeah i was talking to
my dad this morning
it was a popular thing it was a big deal
when he was a kid
in indiana
yeah he was in dc stevenson state
that was the hugest state ever was
indiana d.c stevens
he ran it then yeah i can imagine
i might make me a claw for a little bit
satin
so i'm saying i need to get something
like that cough that's screw this down
yeah is that hot this one's real hot
in the wintertime i remember when i was
younger and i got my first robe i got
one a cloth
and all the officers told me not to ever
get one sat and it'll be hotter than
hell
then being pure wizard you gotta have
one to say
so what is the difference between a
grand dragon imperial wizard
piro wizard's over the whole clan the
whole group
and the grand dragons over the state
like he's the graffin dragon in north
carolina
the man over there is the grand dragon
from florida
so each clan has grand dragons over the
state and then under them they have
exalted cyclopses which is presidents of
each individual unit
and you've been in the clan since how
long about 23 24 years during 1997.
i know that how did you join what
what happened well i was at a walmart
one day and a guy walked up handed me a
flyer
telling me that there's a clan rally
right up the road and won't know if i
would attend it
i had a confederate flag shirt on and i
guess that's the reason why he gave me
the flyer so i wind up attending the
rally
and to me at first i was skipped it
because you hear all the bad stuff about
the clan
killing people and all that so i got a
flyer while i was there for the next
rally telling me when to come it was
basically the invitation to show the
people at the gate on how to get in
because without the paper i couldn't get
in
because i wasn't a member so the second
rally was i think it was
within a month after i went back again
just to hang out mingle with the people
see what they're about
and when i got done listening to a lot
of the speeches i felt you know they
believed the same way i do so that's
what made me join i mean they're against
drugs
or against abortion homosexuality race
myths and everything in the bible
is basically the same thing the clinton
clan was talking about the clan was
telling you
you know race missions wrong is wrong
but all this is in the bible
and that's one thing i liked about the
clan is they were showing me where to
find it at in the bible
and you know i've been to a lot of
churches and most of the churches are
501 c
3 churches they're owned by the
government ran by the government they're
told what to preach
so a lot of the verses they were showing
me in the king james version of the
bible was verses i've never seen or
heard
so it shocked me and i found it very
knowledgeable so i kept going to the
rallies and i kept reading the bible and
then wind up becoming a member of the
ku klux klan in 1997 and i think by
the summer yeah by the time summer was
over i was a full-blown member of the
kkk
and i don't regret a bit of it i mean
i've loved the klan and i always
love to clan and do whatever i can to
help it grow what's the basic belief
behind the ku klux klan
the basic belief behind the ku klux klan
is that
you know as a race as a whole we need to
stick together all the other races are
sticking together you have
you know groups for the
african-americans you got black panthers
black lives matter
uh you got naacp but if you look there's
no white groups out there to support
white people that'll actually stick up
and stand for white people
and help them out when in need you know
the [ __ ] the mexicans they can all run
to the government and get loans and get
welfare while
a white man can't do it it's impossible
basically for whites to go out and get
these services
so the klan to me it's always stood
there to help white people who are in
need and i'll always support it and i
think the klan's a great organization
and it's been here 150 years in support
of the white race and
right now in america the way things are
going it's a double standard on the
media
every time you turn around the blacks
are riding i think it's time for the
klan to rise back up and
do it all again we need to actually get
up and fight for the white race or there
ain't going to be no white race
but what's what's the biggest issue for
the klan today is it immigration
or race mixing or separatism it's a
little bit of
both i mean we've got more immigrants
right now immigration is costing the
united states american taxpayers 320
billion a year
and that's illegal immigration i mean
that money could be spent
on other things like helping our
veterans helping the homeless
whether they black or white the clan is
not a hate group like i tell people
we're not about hate we just want to
live separate from the other races just
like the bible attended
you know that's one of the things the
preacher showed me a long time ago he
was was at a clan rally and i recognized
a lot of the
clan a lot of clan ralliers we had a lot
of preachers there
and you know and he showed me the bible
verse leviticus 19
18 because you always hear people holler
love thy neighbor but then when you read
the verse for yourself it says love thy
neighbor of thy people
and my people are white people so that's
exactly what i'm doing is carrying out
you know god's wishes i want to love my
people and help my people just as every
other race has the right to help
and benefit their race i mean that's it
they should have the right to do that
and i feel right now in america we're
losing our right
as white people as the white race to
defend ourselves or
to even speak out you know if you say
you're proud to be white they pretty
much label you a racist
and to me that's just a racist is just a
made-up word i mean it was made up by a
communist
jew named leon trotsky in 1936 was the
first time that was used during a debate
and he was using it to cut people down
and if that's the way they're going to
use it then i'm i guess i would be
considered a racist and i'm proud to be
a racist
and the klan is a christian organization
yes christian organization we read the
same bible everybody else does we just
actually
read all the bible instead of skip
through like these
judeo-christian preachers do today what
are the aspects of christianity that the
clan is based on
let's base the whole our ritual the clan
ritual like when you get naturalized
or which naturalization ceremony is a
clan ceremony
we use the bible to swear you in and to
become a full-fledged member of the clan
so i mean we want to stick by the laws
of god
and you know you ain't going to make it
to the kingdom of heaven unless you
stick by the laws of god so that's
one thing we try to teach in our family
you know this was taught 30 40 years ago
i remember
you know you wouldn't see colored people
mixing and going into a church 30 years
ago not in this state
and now the preachers are allowing it
and to me it's sickening
and it's sickening to see these
preachers sell out their congregations
and damn their own
congregation straight to hell by pushing
all this equality nonsense knowing that
the bible says all the races should be
separate
and that when christ comes back he says
he shall separate all races again
separate all people
by their tongues and put them in their
own nations that's in matthew 15.
so i mean to me the bible and the clan
go hand in hand
chris i'm going to ask you and maybe
take off your sunglasses when you answer
it
no i'll take off my glasses you want to
keep mine yeah for right now dude
okay are you hoping to take them off at
all no
no okay i used to but they this thing
got so bad where now if they see me on
tv they
wherever i work at uh they usually
terminate me
okay i understood i've done lost two
jobs now for being in the kkk
is that right yeah yeah what does it
take to become a imperial wizard
you have to be in the clan for years
like i joined it when i was
17 just turned 18 and
you got to know all four of your degrees
which is what these are for like this is
knights camellia fir this is your first
degrees caving are you second degrees
knights committee second degree
third degrees knights of the great
forest and then your fourth and final
degree is knight's the midnight mystery
and what you guys have problems you know
you want to stay separate from
african-americans mexicans jews
arabs chinese it don't matter i won't i
would love to see a white homeland
established one
gay community as well the what the gay
community as well their abomination gay
people supposed to be put to death upon
sight and that's in romans 11.
it's also in leviticus 23 uh 2013
homosexuals so supposed to be put to
death upon sight
are there still lynchings anymore no the
clan ain't never
lynch people that's that's another myth
that i helped destroy
years ago when i was doing an interview
for fox as i told them
show me a picture of the clan lynching
somebody and their robes and a black
person hanging and to this day nobody's
been able to produce a picture because
it never happened
and like i told people look it up
lynchings were common by what they call
lynch mobs back in
and if you look at the photos of
anywhere where a black person's hanging
you don't see kkk people you see the
towns people because it was a common
event back then
when somebody committed a crime they
hung them and the whole town would come
out there and have popcorn for sale
basically like it's basically like one
big carnival but yet
that got pushed on the clan a lot that
the clan went out and lynched these
people
look at any picture of any lynch and
you'll see it ain't the kkk it's the
town's people themselves
the community you're living in here in
north carolina there's quite a few
people of african-american descent yeah
and
is there friction between the the races
here
well one thing i like about where we
live at is we all pretty much stay
separate
i mean america can push the myth that
we're all equal and
we're all living in a multicultural
society but in reality
america is more segregated now than it
was 30 years ago
or 50 years ago i mean every time you
walk into a church on sunday
it's segregated when you go to the
prisons the race is segregated so
there ain't no racial tension in this
side of north carolina now you go
towards charlotte and raleigh it's
probably a lot of racial tension but
up here it's it's a peaceful community
everyone says to themselves everyone
pretty much stays to themselves
how has the clan changed over the years
to me the klan has become more
modernized to me
it ain't like it was when i joined you
know it was more secretive back when i
was younger
and and some clan groups still want to
keep themselves in the shadows
and do things while we in the loyal
white knights of the kkk were more open
we'll go out march in the streets
we'll march through towns and do
courthouse public demonstrations while
back
you know years ago a lot of clans
wouldn't even think about doing stuff
like that they
they didn't want people knowing who they
were they was worried about their
identities like i said
i've lost two jobs from it but i still
haven't quit doing it and
i'll continue doing it until the day i
die
and so i think the klans more nowadays
is actually coming more out into the
open
and 10 years ago it was kind of harder
to get people to join but now with all
the
racial tension in america people are
joining left and right so i think it's a
good thing
when these people were riding and
causing all these rights for
a black guy named george floyd who was a
career criminal
the man was just let out of prison for
an armed robbery he broke into a woman's
house a pregnant woman and put a gun to
her stomach
and made her give over all her cash and
credit cards he pulled five years in
prison gets out goes in a store trying
to pass counterfeit money off
counterfeit bills trying to buy more
alcohol and cigarettes and gets killed
by the police
i feel no sympathy for him the man's a
criminal
and i think these riots are helping the
clan grow there's more people out
looking for us now
it used to be we had to go out recruit
members now we just sit back and they
come to us
what do you what do you think about the
state of our country do you think things
are getting worse
i think it's a racial powder keg about
to explode and i'm we're actually hoping
for it most of the people in the clan
want it to
we want the racial team we want a race
for a full out race war
and racism is a big issue in the united
states racism is always going to be a
big issue anywhere you can't have
two different races or three races you
can't have as many people living on one
continent with this many different
religions as many different cultures
without one trying to step on the other
i mean that's just common sense but
you could argue that the clan is
contributing to the problem no no the
clan ain't contributing to a problem you
can just sit back let the blacks
do their own job i mean let them keep
killing each other in record numbers we
ain't got
the clan ain't got to go out and kill
blacks no more we just drop off some
liquor in their town
and some guns and they do it themselves
if it was my option every weekend i
would go up chicago with a big truck
full of whiskey and
crack marijuana and a ton of guns and
bullets and tell them have at it and
just drop it off right in the middle of
town
and then go home and watch my monday
morning news and laugh the whole time
what's the most important thing you've
learned in your life
to never turn my back on god he'll
always be there for me
and like i said the clan's a religious
movement when i was younger i really
wasn't into religion but
and i see there's a whole new generation
coming up that are basically
and i feel sorry for them so i try to
reach out to people about the bible and
the goodness
of the bible and you know god's there
for everybody who's there willing to
listen
what are you proud of stuff in your life
my kids
you have two boys yeah two boys and are
they involved in the clan at all
they've been involved in the clan they
were basically born into the klan
they've been going to rally since they
could crawl you know on the rally field
so
yeah they they feel the same way we do
you know they are seeing that
you know i didn't raise them to be
racially aware that's the thing is
we took them to rise when they were
little as they got older they wanted to
hang out with little black kids down the
road the little mexican kid so my wife
was against it and i told her i said
that's the best thing for them
let them go out there and meet these
other cultures and these other races so
that you know they used to hang out the
black kids down the road and the mexican
kids i thought it was funny i think it
lasted about eight months
and then my kids come home one day and
said i ain't hanging out with them no
i'm like why and they're like well every
time i turn around
my stuff's getting stolen out my room
and i'm finding you know in the little
black boys room down the road
so they pretty much put it together the
cells that these people you know they're
they're not civilized african-americans
mexicans these people are not civilized
asians they're not civilized you've got
asian gangs tearing up california every
weekend
have you traveled to other countries
i've traveled all over the united states
the klan's an american-based group and
it should always have
american citizens as its members we
shouldn't have germans you know they got
a nazi party if they want something
similar to the clan let them stick with
the nazi party
so who are you going to be voting for
this fall
so far we're still going to vote for
trump even though he's pretty much
selling us out every time i turn on
television he's given more and more
money to the jews in israel and to me we
don't gave enough to that country we
give 38 billion a year
in foreign aid to israel and i don't get
why we keep giving to these people
uh i don't care for the holocaust lie i
wish they'd gone tell the truth about
the holocaust that
you know it was our soldiers who've done
the killing of the jews
and i think they should tell the truth
that we bomb the concentration
camps thinking that they were military
bases
of the germans and we're basically it
would be the american government the
british government canadian government
were responsible for the holocaust it
wasn't the germans
but to me the we could use that 38
billion dollars could help the veterans
could help homeless i mean
right now our economy is in a lot of
trouble we could use that 38b and i
think we should cut all foreign aid to
israel
or israel hail as a lot of people like
to call it around here because that's
all it is it's a nation that was stolen
from the palestinian people and they
have no birthright to it if anybody has
a birthright
israel it'd be the chosen people the
white race just as the bible says
was your family racist when you were a
kid nope no my
parents actually hated the fact that i
joined the clinton when they found out
they were actually upset
and told me to get out of that type
stuff and
you know it took them i think about six
seven years ago my mama called me and
she said you know what i'm
i changed my mind she said i'm kind of
proud of what you've been doing you know
marching in the streets for the white
race and she said i'm kind of proud she
said everything that
you know over the years of talking to
them they finally started looking into
what i was saying and they found out
it's all true you know the jews control
the media and the bank and they're using
it
basically as a weapon against the white
race
that's why our money has federal reserve
note on top of it is no better than
toilet paper
i mean it ain't even a real currency
that's why other nations are turning
away from the u.s dollar and i think
that's going to be the eventually
collapse of our country
is the way russia china and all of them
are turning away from the u.s dollar our
dollar is basically worthless
and like i said i hope one day our
economy does fall and people could
actually see who the
behind the banks who's behind the media
and who's trying to tell us it's okay
even though we're living in a concrete
jungle that's what america is a concrete
jungle
there's blacks killing whites in record
numbers that's the fbi statistics say
they kill close to half a million whites
every year while whites kill blacks at
30 i think it was 3
30 and 586 blacks got killed by whites
last year
but they killed half a million of our
people so i think
you know why ain't this info on the news
why don't i have to go to the government
websites to get it
that's because the jews are covering it
all up
and our tv is becoming more degenerative
every time i watch the television
i get sick because i'm starting to see
more homosexuality on tv more race mitz
and propaganda
push down my throat so i turned off my
cable i don't have satellite or nothing
if i want
to watch television i go through the
internet and download the movies i want
to watch
so i watch a lot of the older television
shows like uh andy griffin uh the
monsters
beverly hillbillies i rather watch stuff
like that than the filth they're trying
to feed me today
all right chris well thank you so much
for talking with me let somebody else